[Applause]
making a short sharp exit an angry crowd
through accusations and eggs at Maltese
prime minister Joseph Muscat as he
escaped Parliament shrouded by tight
security hours earlier his chief of
staff and two ministers resigned the
fallout of a police investigation
gathering pace into the murder of
prominent journalist Daphne coruña
Galicia
kara Juana Galicia an investigative
reporter described as a one-woman
WikiLeaks was blown up by a car bomb two
years ago she had become known for
exposing cronyism within the country's
political and business elite although
three men face trial for carrying out
the murder the mastermind has not yet
been identified last week a suspect
believed to be a middleman in the murder
was arrested but the prime minister
granted a pardon if the man helped find
the mastermind the next morning a
Maltese businessman was apprehended on
his luxury yacht
allegedly preparing to flee the
businessman too is now reportedly
seeking immunity in exchange for
cooperating with the police
protesters say Cara Juana Galicia was a
victim of what they call endemic
corruption at the highest levels of
Maltese governments muscat stop aid has
been questioned by police over the
murder the other two ministers say they
were stepping aside until the
investigation was over while denying any
involvement in the death all three were
accused by Kara Juana Galicia of
corruption her family say the Prime
Minister is protecting those behind her
murder
Muscat has ignored calls for him to quit
allora unquote yet in completely hood
this is unit in the undeb zone the
country needs stability that moment is
on dubs own stability my mandate my
actions and decisions in the coming
hours and days will be aimed to ensure
that stability is maintained protestors
say democracy in the country has long
been
the slide the more broken in more ways
than one
but Keith McAuliffe is a journalist with
The Times of Malta he joins us now from
the Capitol Valletta welcome to the
program Keith last night we saw the
Prime Minister pelted with eggs three of
his allies have already gone is he next
that is the question everybody is asking
the Prime Minister himself had said two
years ago when he had won another
mandate to govern for five years that
this would be his last term the problem
for the prime minister is that he's
probably made his biggest miscalculation
his biggest error of judgment in his
political career because for this
Minister his chief of staff has been
there to leave and resign because of
their panama companies initially which
was three years ago for three years and
the Prime Minister had vouched and
pledged it who would be personally
responsible and shoulders possibility
for his decision now that these people
are under investigation over a contract
killing there is no other way no other
way practically for him then resigned
because he committed them big
miscalculation of judgment even though
many people can't believe he was
absolutely nothing about what was going
on now Daphne Cara Juana Galicia she was
murdered more than two years ago now
when you look back at the events of the
past week how close are we to finally
finding out who orchestrated who ordered
her murder undoubtedly there was a big
step forward in the last few days there
has always been such there have always
been suspicious that because this could
be politically motivated because
definite Kawana galicia primarily wrote
on corruption claims involving
politicians and her biggest story which
she was yet to reveal what she had given
notice she was investigating was this
power station in corruption claim that
politicians had received bribes or were
due to receive bribes in return for
giving the the contract the lucrative
millions of euro contract the fact that
now there are suspects who are openly
under interrogation mentioning mr.
Schembri and maybe more cabinet members
it's a big step forward because before
there was it was more of like
speculation at least in the in the
public eye now the family of daphne cara
wanigan it's you have been very vocal in
there
criticism of the Prime Minister what is
it exactly that they would like to see
from him now of course they would like
him to completely resign to move away
out of the political scene and to bring
the masterminds those who really were
behind this
this contract killing to justice there
is speculation that it could have been
more than one mastermind there is
speculation that it could have been two
three or four persons possibly
politicians who poured money into a
kitty to make this contract killing
there is also no this is just
speculation it could have cost more it
would have cost millions this killing
journalist Keith McCauley from The Times
of Malta joining us from the capital
Valletta thank you